okay it says live
something terrible just happened to my
prior setup i didn't do anything and it
crashed and ended it
so no one's in here yet let's wait and
see as people filter in
it might be a second
we got two people in what a shame there
was like 700 or 800 people in here
and then it didn't work yep fixed guys i
don't know what the heck happened i
didn't press anything it just
crashed on me so i'll give it a minute
as more and more people filter in
all right we instantly got 300 this is
good
all right i'll give it a minute because
no one likes i've gone into live streams
before and everyone's like waiting for
it to kick off oh my god oh they're
coming in now
yeah guys to all you just filtering in i
don't know what just happened i didn't
press anything i didn't end it it
literally just went poof
all right anyone wondering what i'm
drinking i'm drinking from huss or who's
whatever brewing company it's called
scottsdale blonde it's a local one to me
it's good stuff
oh my god you guys are wonderful if you
guys want to leave all right let's see
if you have a question or a comment
leave a super chat
let me type this in
love
jimmy
pin message
all right here
all right guys
jesus
all right so to all of you looks like
you're all back 730 we got people here i
don't know what just happened i didn't
press anything it was showing i'm live
and also it showed it freeze on my
screen and it said ended so anyways
let's go
first of all i have the time my life in
peru uh i mean i said the same thing
about egypt but it's like going to these
other countries
is like a dream come true it's like
just a few years ago i'm making a
picture or a video on pictures of machu
picchu that i found on the internet
and then i was there
firsthand with brian forrester who was
the man who inspired me first i've
shared this before um to some of you
that might follow me on social media
that i was sitting on the couch in 2015
i was depressed i was going back to
school and i wasn't really happy about
it i was married we weren't doing all
that great and um oh my god
zetticus zorander 25 bucks thanks
brother do you have a question or a
comment
um wow so we got a thousand people in
here now
wild
all right so let me start over to
everyone that just the stream had just
crashed i don't know why i didn't do
anything we're going to do this a little
bit of a ghetto setup because i was
experimenting with the um streaming
software for the first time today i'm
like now is not the time to fuss around
so i brought over a little tv so we're
going to do straight up powerpoint stuff
there's jimmy showing his sweet ass at
all
oh yeah
oh yeah on tombow or alien tombow how do
you say that
um hold on a second here
all right so hey guys if you have a
question or a comment just throw me a
super chat i'm super grateful um someone
just gave me
a thousand yen that's amazing oh my god
you guys are generous
all right so let me start off let me
just carry on with this as more people
filter in i have a few things to say
first of all
if you have any desire to go to some
ancient sites
now is the time to do it
i don't know if you're paying attention
to our
quick changing world
um but if i were you
i would travel now instead of waiting
till later i would pull the trigger
because i don't know where you stand on
certain things involving mandates
uh but someone like me without getting
into it i don't want to make this the
topic of conversation
but um something tells me that
this isn't over yet whatever this is
and i think that if you want to travel
now is the time to do it sooner rather
than later and there's nothing more
liberating than traveling the world at a
time like now
when all the other people traveling are
in the same exact mentality as you
they're tired of sitting in the house
they want to get out and do something
they want to see sights and and it's so
funny so there's 35 of us in peru
and that included brian forrester and
ben of uncharted x
and everyone was saying the same exact
thing which is that this is a bucket
list item a lot of people saying i never
thought i'd get a chance to do it but
here i am
um thank you to these other super chats
by the way um hey real quick can you
guys hear me well let me look at the
comments because we're at 1400 people
and i want to make sure this sounds good
before i uh
in case there's any tweaking i need to
do
do you guys hear me well press one
if you can hear me well
press one if you hear me well press two
if it sucks
i'm hearing yeah press the number one
i'm not seeing one single one but
everyone's saying fine
wow this chat is blowing up
all right so let me get to it a couple
things one if you have a desire to go to
peru or to egypt
brian forrester and his company hidden
in couture.com gets my highest
recommendation
he's a really good guy i spent two weeks
with him and his wife renee and they are
absolutely wonderful people extremely
down to earth they have good hearts and
i trust them
and that is what goes further with me in
life than anything else is trust
um
so we are going to egypt october 1st
through the 14th however i will only be
able to be there for the first few days
i was gonna have to cancel and pull out
for a few reasons um but that's not good
and and we didn't want the tour to fall
apart so
if you want to go to egypt
now now's the time to do it i mean
not the future isn't certain we're going
to go there next march on a big old tour
so if that's something you want to wait
for you can do it then ben from
uncharted x is going in the second week
of october hold on you guys saying
you're not hearing me well is it that
bad because if so
let me know right now
um but anyway so i'm going to be there
for the first four days um it's going to
be hell for me as far as the travel to
like going to egypt with a nine hour
time difference and then coming back
but um
all right so i'm seeing a bunch of
people here don't like the sound this is
lame i'm wearing freaking earpod pros
they should be all right i'm seeing a
bunch of ones here all right the show
goes on
anyway so here's the deal if you guys
are interested in going to egypt with
brian forrester and i october 1st
through the 14th he'll be there the
entire time i'll only be there for the
first four days which sucks but i will
be going in march and again i didn't
want to pull out of the thing
so you'll at least get a chance to
explore the giza plateau with me and a
few other amazing spots like the serpium
with the 100 ton stone boxes so i'll
discuss that more later in this video
but i want to throw out there now
because i know some people are curious
um so let's see what questions you guys
have
um and let me actually
while i see questions come in all right
jimmy your content i appreciate your
investigation thank you d smith
do you think the atlanteans are still
here and what's the ufos aliens actually
are okay so that's gonna have to be a
video um
so i believe in aliens i think we're
half hybrids if you really want to know
what i think
um but i'm what i'm seeing on the news
and this other stuff is so orchestrated
the timing of it during the middle of
the pandemic was something else and i'm
like
guys i think it's us
it's not to say it's not alien tech but
i'm seeing the timing of all these
releases and everything is so
manipulated so orchestrated the timing
is
it feels like they're experimenting with
us to see how we'll react so i think
it's a combination of things but i'll
save that for another video holy crap we
got 2 thousand people here
um do you guys bring your own beer
you guys are so generous so let me tell
you something first and foremost it's on
my mind i have a few things on my mind
the people of peru
are some of the most wonderful people
i've ever ever met in my life the vibe
that they put out how
just giving and friendly they are i
gotta be honest with you guys
i feel like the united states is a bit
sick and not just the united states i
mean i was talking to people from sweden
and switzerland canada um other parts of
eastern europe and on this tour and
they're saying the same thing guys like
this place has gotten
ugh people that the vibe people are
frustrated oh my god who just gave me
100 bucks was that d smith oh that's the
first one dude i didn't realize it was a
hundred dollars
i don't even know what to say d smith
where are you i owe you a beer with that
hundred bucks that is extremely generous
um but here's something to say first and
foremost that i i'm all over the place
because i got a thousand things to say
and by the way i'm gonna be showing you
guys pictures on this i know it's not
the best setup but it's kind of fun
so guys there's a real serious problem
going on at machu picchu right now
and
you're going to be like shocked to hear
this so
they are in the process
a slow process it's going to take a
couple years
of shutting down machu picchu
to the public
what they're already doing is preventing
people from anyone from going to the top
where all the megalithic stuff the most
impressive parts of machu picchu are off
limits i did not get to go up there let
me show you
well
how do you guys like that
isn't that hot what do you think should
put on my dating profile
um so let me show you guys the view that
i had
so look at this i forgot the name of
this thing but that's the only view i
got of it you couldn't go up to the top
you're only down below it
as well as what is it the so-called sun
temple or whatever you want to call it
instead of going up here with you know
the thing with the big old three big
windows
this is my view like 50 feet down maybe
40 feet
you cannot go up there
they are in the process of shutting it
down over the next couple years to where
they want it to be a virtual
only
so people will drive to machu picchu
they'll take the train there and there's
a whole town down below it's lovely
and they want you to watch it through
virtual reality
and the reason is
you ready for this
conservation
so let me explain to you when we were
demanding that we go up here
and brian for they're like sorry they
have they have bodyguards they have
actual security there to prevent you
from doing it and brian force is like
why
what do you mean we can't go up there
and they said
quote
conservation and we're like oh hold on a
second let me just say
i am all for conservation of these
ancient sites
great
but let me just clarify something
these stones have been sitting up in
high and the blaring
sun in high elevation sun i should say
which is extreme compared to even here
in arizona i'm in arizona right now guys
and you know everyone knows what the
heat is like out here
it's worse up there i i burned it
in minutes it was unreal i'm still
peeling like hopefully you can't see it
but all right so besides the wind rain
and it gets heavy rain up there and
weather for thousands of years all of a
sudden they're like now you just can't
go up there at all because we want to
preserve it i'm like okay i want to
preserve it too
so if you want to prevent me from
touching it like prevent me from
touching it
fine
if you want to keep me far enough away
from it up top to where i can take
pictures of it cool
i mean that sucks i want to go
jimmy can't do anything to this granite
just like the sun and the wind and the
rain hasn't done hardly anything to it
for the last few thousand years minimum
it might be older than that don't get me
going on that just yet we'll see that
we'll save that to beer number two or
three
um
guys this is serious
so brian forster was warned of this a
few years ago three years ago they said
yeah that's the plan we're gonna turn
this into a virtual thing only and here
we are now in august of 2021
and they're literally like sorry you so
let me just clarify if you haven't been
to the machu picchu i can show you some
other pictures
the highest part of it is where all the
biggest megalithic stones are and then
down below you have the little stuff
like this let me show you some other
photos so you kind of get the idea of
what i'm talking about this is a good
photo because you see like the
impressive stuff and then it gets
not as impressive down here
um you can't get up there i can't even
get a photo
for conservation i'm like hold on a
second
if if the plan is to get to where nobody
is allowed up there
what's the point of conserving it
so like no one can see it for the for
the end of time
what's the point of preserving anything
if no one's going to [ __ ] see it
it's stupid and i i'm convinced that
there's other reasons to it i think and
this is conspiratorial but i don't care
i'll just say it um some of the most
impressive things that i saw throughout
the entire country were off limits now
and they have like even some of the
places and i'll show you a picture in a
second
of like they have like glass over it to
where you came and get a good photo
um
guys there's something really serious
going on and ben from uncharted x we
were talking about this like because we
have to do something we got to use our
following of following to whatever best
we can to at least push back on the
peruvian
antiquities government whoever's in
charge of it because this is like it's
unbelievable what's happening let me
just clarify you cannot get up to machu
picchu
you get down below with all the other
cool pretty stuff and you can take a
good photo here let me let me let me
show you guys a great photo
guys they have a policy note machu
picchu where this well that's not a
selfie but selfies are prohibited and
they give you a little brochure when you
walk in with all the rules
and
selfies one of them it's prohibited you
cannot take a selfie at machu picchu
they didn't say why
um does that make any sense to anybody
like does that
tell me that's not insane and by the way
you don't get to go walking around
exploring you're on a you're in a line
it's like disneyland you're in a line
and you go around and they they escort
you with multiple
security people they don't teach you
anything
put that aside like they're not they're
not they're not playing around guys so
i'm gonna have to be very creative and
i'm gonna partner with ben on to see on
what the best way to proceed is
because this is unacceptable like
everyone has a right to see these sites
if they want to stop me from touching it
with my own hands and climbing on it
that's different i'm not going to fuss
about that although i'm going to show
you pictures of jimmy climbing on things
and hopefully i don't get a good old fat
old band from peru but hey guys i needed
the shot so let me show you like a quick
example and because i need to address
this early on because i know people get
so mad at me
um
where the hell is the photo
where is it here we go
enjoy
i this is i can't pronounce it correctly
i have it written down it's like coley
and atombo or coley killer some
forgive me guys these words are so
exotic that it's way different than any
espanol i've ever learned in my life
um it's inca it's different and um but
look at this
you see this
get mad if you want
jimmy needed the shot and you know the
reason why i climbed up there two
reasons one i was informed that you have
to ask permission from the site i did
that
i won't get into what exactly that means
but i did it
um or actually i will tell you what
means you're supposed to ask the ancient
site for permission and i did i went up
there with complete sincerity i wanted
to document it i want to give it to my
love and respect but more importantly i
needed to share that because i've never
seen anybody get up close to it to where
you can actually touch and see the
precision of this because look at this
what is this some sort of sundial some
sort of calendar
um
but i need to get up there and i wanted
to film it up close and i did
and it was i was videotaped the entire
time and this is just a little rope
around the site let me show you another
picture
um
but the point is is that if you guys
follow my social media and the stuff i
was talking about in egypt i was
breaking all kinds of rules i'm like
can't climb on this you can't do that
but i needed the shot
and
it's not just to get a good picture it's
to share it because like guys let's be
real some i'm blessing that many of my
videos will get a million views and like
people need to see this these are things
that i've never seen with my own eyes on
the internet despite looking as much as
i can
and so i'm like someone needs to do it
and i'm like
this thing has been sitting at ten
thousand five or actually up here i
think it was twelve thousand feet
for thousands of years despite the high
elevation blaring sun the wind the rain
the weather and it's fine and jimmy with
his jeans and his new balance sneakers
are not going to cause any harm to that
whatsoever
you could shoot my body out of a
freaking cannonball or like a cannon
right into this thing smack into it and
nothing wouldn't make a dent in this
thing
i think some of these rules are a little
bit
silly
but i also say it with total respect for
the people of this land and and i
understand why people like hey don't we
can't just having everyone climb on it
right because people will vandalize it
will graffiti it they'll do this stuff
to it and we know this
but
you know me being video recorded the
entire time i'm like i'm sorry i feel
like i owe it to you guys
my million plus subs followers
to get
appropriate documentation so i can share
this in real videos shots that i've
never seen so i'm going to these sites
guys consciously thinking to myself like
okay i've seen these places online video
pictures but i have never seen up close
and anything else so i'm like
you know let me take this type of
picture or video of it all right so hold
on someone gave me
what's czk is that uh someone give me a
thousand of it you guys are blessed who
has a question
oh my god champion gaming you make my
bob's tingle have my kids
for 6.99 of canadian money well
i don't know we'll have to see about
9.99 it's kind of my threshold to start
having kids with somebody you can
we'll see how it goes
oh my god this is hilarious all right so
hold on i got a whole bunch of other
ones here and i don't want to miss
um so okay someone lobbed me a question
here via super chat and i'll uh bang
away
all right
um so let me say a few things to
everyone that's just tuned in and then
i'm gonna get on with all the other
things i have to say because there's
like almost 4 000 of us so couple things
i'm going to egypt the tour is with
brian forrester october 1st through the
14th he will be there the entire two
weeks we're going to all the notable
spots special access permissions to go
down in the paws of the sphinx
two hours alone in the great pyramid
down to the assyrian all the great
things
i will be there for only the first four
days because of
certain reasons that i won't share with
the internet but
the good news is that i'll be there for
a full two weeks in march
so to anyone but here's the thing if you
have a desire to go to egypt i recommend
going now because i don't know if you
guys are paying attention
congress is looking to pass legislation
on requiring
shot mandates to get back into the
united states for everybody
but here's what i'm trying to tell you
if you want to travel now is the time
so if you've ever had a desire to go to
egypt i would recommend to go sooner
rather than later there's some open
spots on our tour
it's going to be wonderful if you want
to go there for much cheaper you can do
it on your own
what's the benefit of going on our tour
is that you have all the convenience
paid for and that there's a legit tour
company that looks after us does all the
freaking dirty work and all things you
don't want to do and and takes care of
us along the way including armed
security and everything else might not
be necessary in egypt the place is
pretty safe but they offer it
and um
furthermore you have access to the
special access sites let me give you an
example the assyrion it costs four
thousand dollars the osiris shaft is
like two thousand dollars
um the the sphinx to go down there down
below i don't know exact cost but
somewhere between two and four thousand
dollars
so if you go
with a group like this it's bang for the
buck but if you want to go el cheapo you
know on your own do that too
um but you know all that being said um
if you want to find out more details
about that go to chemetology.com
or look on my
my community post or go to brian
forrester's website it's super easy to
find i'll talk about this in my next
video but there's some open spots if you
want to do it do it
i'm going to go back to peru next august
with brian we're working on details of
that i mean it's not set in stone but
we've we verbally talked about it
again
the plan is to go to egypt in march of
next year so i'll be there for the whole
time but if you want to go the egypt uh
this october um i'll be there for the
only the first four days it's gonna suck
to only be there that short of time the
flight to and from it's a little rough
on me but i'm not canceling the whole
freaking thing i'm going to be there so
at least you'll get a chance to walk
around the giza plateau and the seraphim
and feel the places with me but
anyway um
let's also talk about oh hold on let me
read a question here we got a member oh
thank you ira you signed up
tim pool is starting a paranormal
mysteries thing temple's great let's see
how much did the trip cost uh to peru is
like 3 800 bucks um and that was for
10 well i was in country for 14 days
or nights
um all right alexander machu picchu is
collapsing the three windows are moving
30.35 centimeters a year on geological
time skill that's blazing fast also two
years ago a tourist fell from one of the
sites while taking selfies okay hold on
rest the soul the person that fell down
but i'm sorry that should not
i
i don't know i get to take a selfie and
if i hey let me i'll sign an nda before
i go in there okay jimmy falls down oh
my poor family doesn't get to sue the
country or machu picchu
um as far as the stuff moving around
well
okay if thinking of
what am i supposed to say i can still i
should still be allowed to get up there
and take a picture if you want to keep
me away from it that's fine but like to
keep me i couldn't get any pictures of
it guys
so that's that's something different but
i appreciate that's an informed comment
and i appreciate it
um let's see what else
here is your mother a jew
shut up like
i not that no
um
why would someone ask that um
let's see here let me go over here
sorry guys
um
i want to keep this going do you think
the anunnaki are real
guys probably i mean never mind the word
anunnaki that could mean anything
what i will say is that
i do i'm very suspicious of what's going
around and around outside of the earth
look yeah i think we're being visited
and i think we always have been and i
wouldn't be surprised if we're
part of that i think that if you were to
go to like various biblical in various
religious texts and replace the word
angels demons sky gods
and other things and replace the word
alien things might make a lot of sense i
think that humans are a flawed species
that don't seem to assimilate in our
environment whatsoever whereas all other
animals and insects everything else do
and we seem to be quite
crazy
it's like
certain dogs that are mixed breeds are
like the best dogs ever and then some of
them are like not
i'm kind of comparing us to that um so i
don't know guys maybe maybe not
but i think it's a fun topic nonetheless
i hear someone say we're ruled by
criminals to change that please look at
the nations of sanity project consider
my invitation to discuss thank you
matthews um okay so let me go down here
and start looking at some cool stuff
um so first of all you guys want to talk
about this precision
as far as lost technology and people
want to talk about geopolymers and
people want to talk about how they did
stuff like this
standby can you guys see that i know
this is a ghetto setup but like it's
kind of fun for me this is in cusco
people want to know how they did all
these
insane polygonal stones or how about
let me find the the
my most favorite at sakse woman
let's see here
here we go
look at this can you guys see this i
don't know if this does it justice but
look at
i've said this in many videos i'm 5'10
which is 178 centimeters
and then pan out
and look at this behemoth wall
look at this behemoth look at
pictures never do it justice to what
your eyeballs see when you were in
person
and i gotta say it's one of the most
wild things i've ever seen in my life
let me show you another photo that's
even better
stand by
here we go
oh wait that's not the one
did i duplicate that
if you guys have been following me on
social media oh real quick if you guys
want to see a lot more photos and videos
go go to my instagram i'm not endorsing
instagram it's owned by facebook don't
even get me going guys i'm not a fan of
that stuff but i got to do it because
this is my gig right
so if you're on instagram
my handle is bright
underscore
insight
there's way more photos and videos on
there than i can share on youtube or
twitter
and so i it's a good spot if you take it
for what it is
um
but let me see here i want to find more
shots of this sakse jamaan
and
hold on
hey guys hang on like half a second
because i'm gonna turn on my ac
it's two seconds away you guys can hear
me because i got my bluetooth on
okay
i'm back
all right
um who else has a comment here before i
show that picture
oh
not
jackie chan ten dollars i love all dog
reads me too because i have so many
photos of these uh
dogs that i met in country so there's
stray dogs everywhere in peru but you i
don't even feel sad for them like i did
in egypt because they're all well fed
people are nice to them some of them are
a bit skittish some of them are very
friendly but like none of them are skin
and bones at all
and
you know
it was kind of wonderful if you guys
want to see something fun
i kind of have mixed thoughts on this
this is new with some alpacas when i
took the photo i didn't realize that
these poor alpacas were being exploited
for money all day long
so i kind of felt bad about it
getting back on track too i was talking
about the precision
so i've wondered before going to peru
what the story is i'm like how do they
do all these insane saw cuts
look at this crap
the nubs we gotta talk about this
so let me just because i'm bouncing all
over the place because i'm having fun
let me just say that there's a couple
things that i discovered or
believed once i had been there which i
was already if you've been following my
videos i've had
strong beliefs
or inclination that the egyptians and
the peru the
pre-inca
were connected in some way that
shouldn't be possible according to
everything we've learned in our
textbooks
and having been to egypt
less than half a year ago or about half
a year ago and now in peru i saw with my
own eyes
definitive evidence that these two
cultures were connected
that's not what you're going to hear in
school i know this is controversial but
there are certain things that are
undeniable such as the precision
stonework that i saw
as well as
the nubs you've heard me talk about the
nubs if you've seen my ancient
connection global connection video i've
talked about these things
and they're all over the place you find
them in throughout different parts of
egypt and you find them in different
parts of peru
as well as other countries
and i'm sorry but like that's not a
coincidence i don't pretend to know what
the purpose of these nubs are but
they're everywhere you see them here
and they're random they weren't for
lifting and i'll make a detailed video
on how you know that
um because some have them some don't
and it's more than decoration like it is
unbelievably random and so guys i'm
going to make a knockout video
the egyptians and the pre-inca were
connected
if you just go there and see some of the
details you'll understand for yourself
like it let's see here
hold on a second here
you guys want to see something wild
so if you go to
oh yante combo which is a fun word to
say oh yante tombo which is like okay
hold on it's hard to see these pictures
this is this site with all the steps
you've seen this before
i love that photo this is me up top of
it but let me just scroll over this is
all yeah and tombow
um
all right so hold on a second here
this is an example of a cut block
it got it goes all the way down through
here what am i pointing at
this is a cut block they did have
precision techniques for cutting blocks
look at this sucker oh baby
but as i'm going to get to in a second
people want to know about
uh polymers and geopolymers i should say
guys this is one big block let me scroll
in
one big block you wanna know where it
came from
hold on wait for it
up here
about a mile away
down here is a river you can't see it
but on the top of here is the quarry for
these 60 to 70 ton stone blocks that's
me holding onto my hat because the wind
was vicious up there
um oops hold on
so these blocks are 60 to 70 tons
the pictures don't do it justice because
you can see them on the other side of
the rope
and there's dozens of them and they were
brought from a mile away
downhill and then uphill
here's another one
and this is what's left and all these
blocks are strewn about the entire
landscape down below like something some
unbelievable cataclysm happened guys i
saw similarities of a cataclysm in egypt
and here and that you had some of the
largest stones just thrown about like it
was an explosion except for they're not
blown up they're like it's like
some it's like something just flew them
all over the place
it's unexplainable they're all in the
same spots that they were when they
landed
and it's completely it's unreal alright
so on let's see try to catch you on
brian's livestream earlier question all
right let me let me ask thanks for the
20 bucks jay
being that some constellations were
depicted in stone at gobekli tepe do you
have or know of a theory of who named
them
jay i don't know brother i wish i did
um
great question but i have no idea to be
completely honest who else has a
question
um
here's another shot of let's see
all right so let me get back to the
point because i'm all over the place
guys but um
like look at this look at this precision
there's no mortar in here and look at
this this is like the size in fact i'm
pretty sure i have a picture of my
finger up to it yes i do
all you get things like this all over
the place with the polygonal stones
it's wild there's no mortar they're fit
together with laser light precision and
i went there wondering
about
you know were these stones cut for
example i'm gonna come back to this oh
my god look at this precision
look at my can't fit a hair in there
look at that [ __ ]
on
it's like this everywhere guys
now here's the thing if you guys want to
get into the wild stuff
here we go
i have a few things to say about
geopolymer and lost technology
in egypt
those are stone cut those those blocks
are are cut at the pyramids and there's
a number of reasons you know this
they're all completely different sizes
if you were casting stone
you would do one offs and do a bunch of
them or no you went through one offs you
would do a bunch of them under one cast
whereas again a giza they're all
different
two the stone quarry is right there you
can see where they cut it out
three
the stone is limestone and there's this
these ancient fossils in coral all stuck
in them and it's clear that they just
cut it right out of the bedrock guys
however i went to egypt or excuse me
peru and this picture is here is that
cusco
expecting to see like all right i assume
that these were cut blocks as well with
like a laser cut precision
what i've learned is a few things and
let me tell you that i now
will tell you that these were not cut
but they were not poured
so first you need to know a few things
local legend claims that
there was
a type of plant that would soften stone
they discovered it by this is ancient
this goes back a long time okay there's
no evidence to support it today
there were certain birds that had bird
nests that would use these plants and
they would put their these plants to
make their nest on stone blocks and
cliffs and stuff like that and people
figured out that like it was like
melting the stone or softening it just
where it was not all the way through
like acid but just a little bit and
there was two plants that would do it
and one of what they were both in high
alt or elevation on the mountains
and the one that was higher up was even
more effective
and with eight what the the local legend
say in
peru
is that
this was done with plants they weren't
cut with saws that they essentially took
blocks and they formed and shaped them
with this plant material or at least the
material of the plant that would break
down and make it into some goo
and they would shape it and get them all
to fit with locking precision now this
is a gap just from earthquakes and this
is what allowed me to stick my fingers
in there which i'm pretty sure have a
picture of me doing it fondling it
it was it was hot
i'll stop this shut up jimmy um
and it was unbelievably smooth i was
expecting to feel like striations of cut
blocks like i did in egypt all over the
place the stones in egypt were cut guys
but this
all at cusco these huge ones which by
the way when you see this picture like
i'm sure there might be a picture of me
next to it my head would be up to like
here this is like freaking huge
and all between them i'm like it's as
smooth as it gets it's like it was quite
literally
formed like
like
like it was not like it was poured and
the reason why is for a few reasons
because there's this
um
marshmallow effect where the bulge on
the outside this is good guys this is
going to require a video so i can
explain this well because i'm doing it
from a live stream with this freaking tv
this is so funny hey there's 40 almost 4
500 people on guys this is surreal you
guys are so nice
cheers anyone wondering what i'm
drinking i said it earlier it's house
brewing company out of tempe arizona
it's called scottsdale blonde it's a
nice light beer i like local and craft
beer
um
kyle said
oh dude kyle
was awesome to hang out with you in peru
and possibly discover a pyramid all
right kyle you're the man i had a total
blast
oh dude i hope your trip back to
montreal was was smooth brother you are
a good guy so guys let me tell you
something real quick before i go any
further if you guys are wondering about
taking a a tour and you're wondering
you're nervous about it because you're
like well i don't know these people who
am i going to meet because even me
before i did egypt i'm like well you
know i'm going to be meeting people that
are subscribed to me i don't know what
to expect
you know and here's the thing
on both tours that i've done
these are the most
nice
friendly like-minded good vibe people
i've ever met in my life everybody got
along
and you make these connections and
friendships that you're gonna have for
the i'm gonna have for the rest of my
life
i mean like and especially if you're
traveling nowadays it's one thing to be
like hey i'm like really into the
ancients i meant to talk about aliens
and conspiracies i'm into all these
topics that maybe people that follow my
channel might be into
and so you know at a minimum you're
gonna go there and have tons to chat
about right
but then like you realize that like if
you're traveling now despite all the
chaos in the world and all the
everything if you guys haven't been
paying attention
you know that you're getting you're
you're connecting with like-minded
people from that regard which is that
people want to get out of the freaking
house
guys get busy living or get busy dying
and if you're nervous to go on a tour
guys i'm telling you like i'm all about
it now i'm gonna be doing this stuff for
a long for forever i won't stop and this
is our group it was 35 of us including
brian ben and myself and we had tons of
other wonderful people people from
sweden switzerland canada different
parts of europe uh mexico
and
and other places of course all different
parts of the united states and guys
these people were wonderful so if you
guys are tempted to do this again i'm
going to egypt's october there's a
two-week tour i'll only be there for the
first four days brian will be four-star
will be there for the entire time going
all the notable sites and again i'll be
there in march for the full-time
and uh ben from uncharted x has a tour
two-week tour
on the second half of october so you
know if those dates don't work for you
go with him ben by the way ben is a
blast to those of you that aren't if
you're not following ben of uncharted x
go subscribe right now same to brian
forrester these people are good people
they're smart they're fun to travel with
incredibly interesting their life
stories are incredible
so
yeah i gotta say it like that um
now hold on let me just respond to a few
more comments because i know i'm gonna
miss them and let me just tell you if i
miss your super chat a question or
comment the good news is that youtube
stores them all for me to be able to
easily read and find them on my uh
creator dashboard so i will not miss it
if i miss it live i'm sorry
um this like you know
i'm doing the best i can but just know
that you know
i'll i'll definitely see it later all
right so someone says do you know about
the 12 000 year cycle of destruction
caused by the sun and earth uh turning
back uh over and back distributes as our
solar system so okay so this is let me
also say two things to go along with
that one there are some incredibly smart
people that i met on this tour
i mean
scientists uh
physics uh professors um pilots all
kinds of interesting people people that
are are stone masons professionally
it's wild on the type of people that
come like brilliant people
and you know having a whole bunch of
conversations
um with people including brian forrester
and other people like guys so that's
probably what happens is instead of
twelve thousand a year i think thirteen
thousand a year with a great cycle um
involving the equinox or uh the um
the tilt of the earth's axis for the
twenty five thousand nine hundred sixty
years
break it down that turns into thirteen
thousand years guys yeah that
i'm really
i'm really thinking there's something to
it
i think it's more than just asteroids
pelting us
i think it's
it might in itself correlate to
geomagnetic pole shifts that i think
will cause a more cataclysmic
event on earth than what scientists
claim will happen they say it's just
going to be a bunch of satellite things
and
and stuff like that and
commun
geo or what do they call it um
communications issues from from
satellite blah blah blah blah they say
that's all that's gonna happen first of
all if that happens you're talking about
a grid down scenario and that in itself
is apocalyptic the grid goes down for an
extended period of time
you can't pump gas the city water pumps
will shut down once the generators run
out of fuel
good luck it's going to be
apocalyptic at that point
but i think that it's worse than that i
think that it will cause crust
displacement let me just say science
this says it won't happen but i don't
think that they can actually prove that
and i think that it might be related to
these cataclysmic events
and when i saw different things in egypt
and in peru where things were scattered
about massive you know 50 ton stone
blocks like they were flown out of the
place i'm like maybe
maybe that's
something like that um okay dee smith
did you just hook me up with another 100
bucks brother
he says i'm a full believer that
governments around the world know and
want to hide the truth from the populace
what do you think could be their
motivation
all right so d smith i agree with you
they're not fools
and i believe that it's related to all
the underground bunkers that they've
built and and probably high speed uh
tr rail systems underground
if you guys don't think that's happening
you haven't done i mean the evidence is
there
there's been remember the last several
years with all these mysterious
earthquakes that were happening
underground all across the u.s going
from east to west over a period of a few
years
so i felt one of them myself
back when i was well i'm in arizona now
but before i moved to boise idaho and
moved back when i was still out so 2015
i'm laying in bed with and it was at
night and there was a boom it was like
the whole house shook just like a like a
knock and i felt it in the bed i was
like i was married at the time and were
like what was that
and the first thing i thought of i was
like because i was in the military and
deployed to iraq i felt controlled
demolitions where they'd get explosives
and ids they'd bury it and blow it up
and you'd feel it you'd be like laying
in your bunk at night and you feel like
this thud it's just a thud just you feel
it under your feet kind of thing
and this is exactly what it felt like
and i immediately said to my wife i was
like
it felt like a nuclear bomb just went
off like 100 miles underground or
something now that sounds silly and
that's not what i'm suggesting but this
happened up in anthem arizona
and i felt what i felt you know on the
news like oh that was an earthquake i'm
like
i felt an earthquake in boise idaho i
know what an earthquake felt like
and this wasn't it
so
where i'm going with that is that yeah
if you have unlimited resources and if
you look back in the 60s and 70s when we
had this advanced
underground network of doomsday bunkers
like
google the cheyenne complex outside of
what is it colorado springs or whatever
it is
look at and that's already retired
go look at pictures of that where they
have like these 14 doors that are like
15 feet tall and like five feet wide and
there's like 15 of them 14 of them
whatever it is
go look at that stuff and ask like so
that's retired and you don't think that
they replaced that of course you would
if you have unlimited money i.e
the u.s taxpayer
of course you're going to freaking build
these things and of course you would
have a high-speed underground
network of tunnels i this is these
aren't just rumors guys i think you'd
we'd be stupid not to have that stuff
so to answer your question dee smith
yeah i think that they are at a minimum
they might not know when something's
going to happen but if nothing else if
there's all the studies that i've done
and i credit around the carlson and
others for their brilliant work on this
like
it is scientifically proven that the
earth goes through cataclysmic events
far more frequently than the general
public is aware and i think that the
worst thing they could do
is is freak the masses out
that's not to say i wouldn't tell you
guys if i knew the world was coming to
land i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
because people have a right to get their
souls right and and and say they're
sorry and get peace with the creator or
whatever they want to do
but i also understand that if you were
in that
res that power and that had that
responsibility then
some people would be better off not
knowing it's coming because this is
going to ruin the rest of your life like
let's pretend you knew you're going to
die 10 years from now
horrifically
do you want to know or do you not want
to know
i want to know if i could choose to know
which day i die i would actually sign up
to know that sound might sound morbid to
some people but then i could
then i could plan it out because you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna coordinate it just right
to where i bounce my last check
and i'm gonna have a good time between
now and then and i'm not kidding
um
let's see here who else has a question
guys thank you all for the super chats
but
um yeah guys so what i saw in peru in
egypt was evidence of cataclysm it
reminded me of the war zone i saw in
iraq where things are just blown apart
and and it's
it's so unexplainable so look forward to
a video on that i'm going to make a
video first on the connection between
egypt and peru and look at instinct
think for yourself
i mean it's apparent for all that advice
to see
and and i i got to say this which is
that
i thought i knew a lot about these sites
of egypt and peru before i went
and then you're there and within minutes
you pick on so many things just like i
was just telling you guys about the the
lack of cutting on these polygonal
stones with oh four four there's 4 44
people that were just watching that's a
good number the angel number you guys
can laugh if you want i'm all about the
woo-woo
um
but anyways so in minutes of going to
these sites there's things that you'll
learn like that which you just can't
learn unless you're there and i'll give
you an example of that in a second but
let me say seth uh blader just said
always a good day when there's a new
video thanks brother i really appreciate
that
um so let me show you guys an example so
you guys know about this site
yeah this riga bell the freaking
stargate look at this sucker
you guys know what i'm talking about i
mean my dorky forgive the photos but you
gotta you gotta take a good shot so this
is what it looks like from outside
and down below you have no idea what
you're looking at because this is the
stairway to get up
and you you can't see the site from
down below hold on how's this thing
doing
hold on
that's the site from down below that's
an even better view see this that's the
cave you walk in you have no idea that
laying in there is this sucker
um and if you want to know what the the
local legends say about this
because no one knows what this is okay
hold on academic this is a
ceremonial site you go there and you
pray that's what they did that's what
the anchor did
ceremonial everything that's literally
the explanation for every single site i
went to
every single site i went to
ceremonial religious end of story
i'm like you know
so this is blue granite which is
particularly strong it's stronger than
the even the granite that the rose
granite that you see in egypt which is
unbelievably strong as well
and they carved this thing out of there
with such precision
and what the locals say is that it was
used as a communication device to the
other so-called stargates
throughout the throughout peru let me
show you another one amaro muru
which is
absolutely freaking incredible so you
all recognize this site
this sucker which is so uniquely
designed i mean they carved it out of
stone with hand it's not an accident
that it's uneven they chose this precise
design for whatever reason
and at this site they claim that it was
used
for to allow your mind to go to another
dimension
that's what they say now hold on i'm not
saying i believe that i mean i
i don't know what i believe in this site
hold on look there's jimmy there how
cute
um is there another one hold on
yeah look at that gives you it gives you
uh an idea for its height but i remember
i have video of this i'll have to show
you guys when i make a video but this
whole thing is way bigger than i thought
like okay so there's brian forrester the
legend himself
and this is like
all right so brian foster is about i'd
say five ten five eleven
and he's kneeling here or scrounging he
can't but it's like oh on this computer
i don't have the other photo but tall
people were like up to here so this is
like 25 feet or so and it's all carved
out of here and there's another shot
hold on
stand by oh jesus
hold on let's go back to the cow i made
friends guys i'm into it y'all into the
whole cow scene get over it um let's go
to this one actually i made friends with
an alpaca
don't get more sexy than that look at
that
you one thing is so interesting these
alpacas are picky
you got to put off a good vibe before
you go up to them i sound spit on
someone else i saw them run from other
people you just got to go up real chill
and cool
um hold on let me read a couple super
chats before i get on to my next tangent
great to see you're back in the states
thank you lotus um i'll be in egypt in
october looking forward to meeting you
yes
look forward to meeting you too that
that means a lot to me
history with kaylee what up awesome
channel excited to see what you bring to
us after this trip love this live stream
jan and i did a collab coming soon can't
wait jana james is awesome and so are
you you guys are great thank you for the
super chat um
so let's see here let me get away from
my animal stuff okay
check out silly astani silastani
this stuff is so much bigger in person
it's unreal
again i'm 510 to anyone didn't hear me
say before and you go up to these blocks
and these behemoths are so unbelievable
i know
by the way let me just say next time i
do this guys live i'll do a streaming
software to i can just show the picture
on screen
i was setting it up this morning and i'm
like what am i doing i'm not doing a day
of is not the smart thing to do so i
just
doing an old school i gave powerpoint
presentations in the military in school
and at a prior job all just like this so
i figured
i'll do it here now
um but let me show you more of these
photos look at this sucker and yes i
went in there through this little hole
and there's human bones in there i'll
show you in a second
look how big these polygonal stone
blocks are
the
this is 500 this is on the hill 500 feet
higher than the 12 500 foot base of the
plateau
um i'll talk to you guys about the
elevation here in a second but
look at this stuff hold on let me see if
turning off this light helps hold on
guys
is that better you won't see me as good
scheisse
oh well
um
so these were said to be tombs but um
and i'm not saying they won't use it
this is me and ben
in a good photo
all right so there's me inside and you
see this
that is part of a human leg
actual bone
and that's oh there's a better shot of
it and i don't have it on this computer
but i have a half of a human
the cranial skull
on one of the other little false windows
notice how this is in a false window
again these false windows everywhere but
this is the inside of this thing and it
just goes straight to the top
this is silistoni the other place was
not silistoni that was a different name
um
forgive me
this is on super this is on ultra wide
angle so you can't see just how big
these freaking stones are
and it makes me look skinnier than i am
because it's again ultra wide angle
but i went in here as well
and this place is wild so here's the
other side it was blown out
all these stones and mortar were put in
there someone tried to bury this thing
this is not original the main blocks are
original and they're super super huge
and this is what the inside looks like
that's looking up into that dome so
previously you saw this that's a dome
and on the inside it's like a cavity
dome just like this
um pretty wild was i allowed in there no
okay well it's fine
get mad at me leave a comment right now
i'm mad at gene for going in there and
disrespecting the sights because brian
foster is putting up awesome videos of
me like getting on stuff and oh my god
some people got so mad at me like this
disrespectful gringo
ah
it's fine guys i had to go get the shot
so you can see what it looks like no one
would know otherwise
but here's what's so cool
it's two sets of blocks on the inside so
those huge behemoth blocks that i just
showed you
on the outside is like basically double
layered most of them
and so in here it's like double layer
just to get in there
and i mean again look at this this is an
ultra wide angle so it distorts the
whole thing it makes it look far more
narrow than it is but picture my hand i
don't i got normal size hands
and like i guess
the point that i'm trying to make is
that these pictures never do it justice
here's the other side of it
and um that's what it looks like
crawling out of it
um
here's some more nubs at the same site
and this is another example of
everything being strong about everywhere
hold on let me just catch up on a couple
of the super chats because they feel
really bad billy thank you for the 20
bucks brother you have to go to jordan
petra is high on my list
um
let's see here guys thank you for the
super chats
michael wiggins do you do shirtless
streams
not yet when it go maybe one day we'll
see how much money would that make me
like hey ladies hey guys you know just
just give me your money here's the you
know i'll do one button at a time
oh you guys are hilarious um ancient
explorer
what's n-o-k
um
what currency is that okay forgive me
um have you heard of the lost city of
petite that is supposedly located in the
jungle of northeast cusco
actually i heard of different things
about the jungles of peru but i don't
know if that's the same thing i'm
thinking of
so i almost want to say no
um but that's something that i'll look
at what i will share with you guys
is a possible pyramid in
in peru
now it's totally not conclusive
it it's just something we saw
hold on please tell me i have the
picture on here
hold on guys
forgive me
um
what a shame
it's not on here
i have all the photos in a different
spot
um
so let's see here
what do you guys want to talk about
i can't believe there's 400 people on
this i'm so blessed
so here's a question
kyle oh it's kyle again the native
americans here say it's okay to go into
the ruins and take pictures and share
nice so let me guys tell you a few
things so they have ropes and stuff to
keep people
one from being too close for other
people to be
in the way of taking photos and there's
people that do vandal vandalism and
other things terrible things like that
i want to know that
i want all of you to know that when i go
beyond the ropes like let me show you a
picture because like i was all about it
i'm like these ropes don't mean anything
to me and i know that sounds incredibly
rude and disrespectful
but i say it with all my heart that i'm
there to document and and share these
things with
hopefully
millions of people is my goal
and
i'm sorry like sometimes it's like you
can't get the best shot if you're on the
other side of a rope with it in your way
and and so what i was told by the locals
there is that for them not the
authorities the locals
can i climb on this and they say you
have to ask the site for permission
which means
literally asking the stone and going
into it with all your heart and just
being grateful and wanting to learn and
bring in
the knowledge of the ancients that did
it and are no longer with us
and i did that i went there with pure
intentions people are filming me the
whole time my new balance shoes and my
jeans can't cause it any harm and i got
some incredibly good shots in the
process and
sorry not sorry like i know that's gonna
piss some people off and they really
really don't like that and i respect
your opinion
but um
sorry guys like i needed the shot
um
let's see you want to see something else
crazy
this huge stone at
yante tombo
here's it from the top so you get like
scale of like how big someone is
compared to it
and on the other side is this like slide
looking thing going on like what the
hell is this this is one of the areas
where like there's these huge stones
thrown about this was not it came from
the very top and was thrown down
hundreds of feet and you have like this
whole
that's the funniest photo ever this was
staged showing off my sweet ass
but you have these
oh hold on a second
hey
you can't see a good photo of this but
this is my first time ever seeing
the
southern sky at night and that's the
milky way
oh this isn't gonna show up
but my cell phone picked that up you can
kind of see it that's the milky way i
thought that was super cool that was
like a cool moment to see that
um but getting back to these thrown
about stones
hold on now
hold on
oh so that's something else i want to
share with you guys so i had a cool
moment but i was hesitant to tell you
guys because i'm like i don't know if
it's something you want to share
so this was a really cool trip for me
and that i so long story short i'm done
with american airlines i won't get into
all the reasons why but they used to be
a great airline and now they're not
so i'm like you know what i'm going to
peru i've been saving up flyer miles for
the last seven years and i'm like on
this trip i had to take american
airlines and i'm like you know what i'm
gonna do i'm i
i'm gonna dump this airline i'm gonna
spend every all of my flyer points and
i'm gonna dump it
and i did so i decided to book a
business class seat to peru
and it was like wonderful
um
it
so i took some photos i'm like should i
share you guys should i not but it's
like good for me like
you know
seven years with the flyer miles and
using that stupid credit card and if you
guys don't have if you guys have a
credit card and you're not getting
something out of it you should really
consider getting an airline credit card
pick your favorite airline and just
start paying never use your debit card
just pay for everything with it and you
get something out of it so here was my
seat it was the coolest thing ever it's
a total lay flat you have like your own
little cubicle look i got my cute little
hat it was on a 787 which the dreamliner
if you guys don't know planes like the
787 is awesome
and um yeah it was awesome like look at
that cool view
um you got a decent meal that was like a
filet it was tasty i mean it's airline
food whatever
this is like inside the cabin it's like
super
i don't know comfortable and everything
and i don't know like i just feel really
blessed about it i didn't pay cash for
it so like if you guys i i'm like do i
share this do i not but like good for me
it made the traveling so much better so
if you're in a position to do a business
class seat
or internationally
it's gonna be really hard to go back
just everything about it was better and
the drinks too
um so this is me my first day in lima
and what's so cool about it
is you see all this
the beach is black sand like volcanic
basalt
and this is on the cliff outside of la
comar so anyone that's been to lima this
is in the miraflores district which is
awesome
and uh and that's jimmy um hold on a
second let me read another one of these
super chats
how do you or how small do these spots
make you feel you know what i mean like
claustrophobic um
not bad i i could be claustrophobic
under some circumstances
but these sites are made out of stone
that has withstood
countless earthquakes for thousands of
years it makes me feel actually safe in
fact
being in these structures and these
small little crevices to me would be the
safest place to be if there was some
sort of disaster or earthquake
just like being in the pyramid some of
it's like really small cramped
spacing to crawl through but i'm like i
actually felt safe in there i'm like
this is where you want to be it's a
safer than any other spot we make
nowadays so
um let's see here
what currency is pln
because i just got 100 of it thank you
uh do you find getting used to the
altitude difficult or easy i'm so glad
you asked this guys it was hell
all right so lima's
sea level
you get up to cusco which is like where
machu picchu is and cusco was 10 500
feet and we were there for
closer to a week and guys it's rough
the height it's the highest i've ever
been at that point i was in telly ride
colorado at like 9 900 feet and that was
rough
um it's you get winded extremely fast
you get sun burnt extremely fast but
even at night i kept and everyone else
did too kept waking up
like just short on breath now there's
things you can do for it you can chew on
coca leaves and they have these candies
and coca tea and it like makes a huge
huge difference
but like it was rough and then we went
to puno which is where like lake
titicaca is guys that's 12 500 feet
it was rough i'm not gonna lie it was
rough
the coca leaves you chew on them you put
in your like here like it's like like it
was chewing tobacco and it makes a
significant difference
but i'm not gonna lie like i thought
after almost two weeks in country i'd
get used to it and i didn't um they say
i
the locals say it takes three full weeks
to get used to the altitude but
i'm not gonna lie
it was rough and it i was really excited
to fly back into lima to get down below
to that sea level
um
yeah
let's see here
harsh zaveri
hi keep up the good work do you think
that ancient global civilization that
you were talking about might be from the
indian subcontinent cambodian temples
etc
so yeah i think that they're all
connected
the locals in in from the inca the
passed on inca legends say that the inca
came first the pre-income we're not
talking about the stuff in the textbooks
and then they went they came from lake
titicaca is what they say spread around
then they went to egypt and then
elsewhere that's what they say i don't
know if that's true but i will tell you
is that the temples and certain uh uh
pyramids in cambodia
uh egypt and stuff in peru i i'm totally
certain they're all connected the nubs
the nubs prove it guys
let me just say you see all these weird
random nubs
that are found all over different places
never mind what they were used for it
doesn't matter
the point is that they're all over the
place in all these countries and it's
unexplainable i've been talking about
this stuff for more than a year you got
other cool uh channels like andrew from
ancient history criticisms you got phil
you got these other cool guys that are
talking about the nubs and like they're
spot on this is a connection it's there
and i would have thought over the last
year that you would have had like the
mainstream skeptics come out and explain
it away guys they haven't it's like
radio silence they don't they don't have
an explanation
so whether they were used for lifting
which they weren't and i can i'll be
able to make a solid video on why they
weren't because you see them in some
places versus others and let me just say
the only explanations you do here is
that well
they shaved them off the other spots but
not here just because they didn't get
around to it i'm like that is
the laziest thing i've ever heard in my
life or among them
and um it's like even stuff like this
nub nub nub nub nub nub
no other nubs
i'm like why not this one you know i
mean and plus those nubs won't be enough
to sustain the weight of it anyway
um
no there's there's another explanation
and the reality is that we're only
seeing it now
in the way that it not the way it was
when it was done thousands of years ago
so i think the answer is just gone if
you really want to know hold on let me
read another super chat because i hate
missing these
jimmy what are your thoughts on hollow
earth oh
well
when you first hear you're like well
that's crazy it's some science fiction
thing but um
there could be caves that could sustain
some forms of life that are miles under
the crust or within the crust
um hollow earth
i mean it's like it makes me think about
like as above so below
it's a wild topic i'm kind of open to it
because i'm one of these open-minded
people that knows that i i don't know
but like
because a lot of people think like these
ufos are coming from in the earth like
if you look at native american stories
as well as aboriginal stories from from
legends from uh australia they all say
that the beings came from down below and
came up and then you have these legends
from historical texts religious texts
from all over the world saying how
beings came down bred with the women and
made us
so like
i'm looking at like these ufo stories
that are coming out and they're talking
about them from being under the ocean so
they have doc all right so the united
states government has documents
documented crafts under the ocean
traveling at hundreds of knots
under the ocean tracked by military
sonar
100 you can't go nothing we understand
can go hundreds of knots under the
underwater i'm like what are they doing
underwater that would be the best place
to hide right so perhaps there's cave
systems
like whether it's like the mid-atlantic
ridge like that place is so vast and
diverse and so the most craziest
mountains that exist on earth probably
might be the mid-atlantic ridge don't
quote me on that but a vast network of
mountains guys there could be caves in
there
four miles under the ocean that we don't
even understand
um i'm open-minded to anything
um let's see ray the nubs or messages in
a language we have yet to decode i've
heard this that is a
very plausible theory i think i it may
have been phil from um uh his channel
phil i hope you're watching this brother
i know that you're doing great work uh
forgive me for i'm on the spot uh
uh but he specializes in adults him and
andrew and everyone else
and like
it's possible it could be telling us
some we're not telling us something but
it was telling someone something it
could be
something just well beyond our
understanding
i'm open-minded to it um but let me keep
going i have a few other things i want
to say
jimmy you should hook up with a virtual
reality company to film sites is the
best way to allow everyone to see these
places with your narrative guys as a
brilliant idea
ben was actually of uncharted x was
talking about this i think it is a
brilliant idea especially as traveling
becomes more difficult with their
ever-changing world that might be all we
have left or if not everyone can afford
or have the means to travel
so or the time so i think that that is a
outstanding idea and um ben was there
doing 3d mapping this time around on all
these sites and that's all it would take
to make that kind of stuff happen
um
so that's a brilliant idea
let's see here adam davis awesome
content do you have any thoughts on the
apparent sun tunnel and anger watch and
possibly some sort of power source
thanks man so i'd have to google real
quick to see what you mean by sun tunnel
uh i'm very familiar with angular watt
but let me um let's see here
i don't want to all right let me get
back to that let me let me just say i'm
gonna be making another video of anger
what anyways and we were talking about
going there so brian like we wanna let
me just without getting ahead of myself
these are just ideas but brian forest
and i are talking about with ben of
possibly going to india in 2023.
uh we want to do a trip to cambodia
there's people talking about doing a
trip to japan to go explore the yanaguni
underwater monument so like guys and and
we're looking at me going with others
going down to mexico to the yucatan
peninsula and going to all those
pyramids down there so let me be clear
balbeck can't go there right now but
that's on the list petra all these
places it's going to happen i'm going to
turn this into like a huge
traveling
future of mine okay what
is sck that's south korean i believe
i think the nubs could point at a
sequence of instrumental nodes like a
meditation music
perhaps a lot of these sites have insane
resonance and although you can't see it
on there oh it's gonna play it through
my phone i can't um so while we were
here me and my buddy matt were literally
drumming on these windows
and the sound was like you were banging
on like this hollow metal
it was like it was like flooding like a
drum loud
um i wish i could play it through my
phone right now but now is not the time
to do it um
but yeah so like all these sites have
crazy resonance
um let me real quick look at my little
syllabi my outline give me a second here
yeah so to anyone that's just showing up
now i want to reiterate this point
because it's so significant and then
we've gone to a few other things
um so machu picchu is in the process of
closing down over the next couple years
they're already preventing people from
going to the tippity top where all the
most incredible sites are the sites i
want to see more than anything they
won't even let us up there couldn't even
get a photo
one day you do it and what they're
saying is that in the next couple years
they want to make it a virtual reality
only site to where people won't even be
allowed up to the top of the mountain at
all you'll come down below you go to the
restaurants and they'll hook you up at
the bottom with some computers and you
can show like a lot of people walking
around with the camera to show you
through a television screen
the dumbest thing i've ever heard in my
life so i'm sharing that right now
because i know those people have tuned
in since i started this chat and they
need to hear it because ben and i like
we were ripped off like i wanted my
money back i'm like what did i just pay
for you you're trying to make you're
making me wear a mask outside at 10 000
feet almost
um in the in the beautiful sun
and i couldn't even go take a picture of
my favorite thing
if you want to stop me from going up
there and touching these sites that's
one thing but preventing me from getting
anywhere near it is insane i don't so
i'm putting that out there because this
is a big deal like the the the people
that are making that decision are wrong
and they're talking all their reason is
for conservation
okay well then like this site has been
sitting outside in the wind and the rain
and the weather and the blaring high
elevation sun for thousands of years and
it's
not even a dent in it and yet you know
so your way what are you conserving it
for then if no one's ever gonna see it
again if you're just gonna lock it off
and not let anyone see it what's the
point
it's stupid
ugh
let's see here
all right so you got some new ones
if you want
src says if you want to switch to plasma
electro electromagnetic cosmology okay
i appreciate the super chat brother
david aloha i'm david love your videos
have you ever thought of visiting malta
certain yes the answer malta absolutely
sardinia and other mediterranean islands
to see
ancient megalithic sites yes um it's not
high on my list but you know it's one of
those places that could end up happening
sooner or
being easy to get to
all right guys i'm only half a beer and
give me a second here to
fix my
parched throat and sorry if you guys can
hear sawyer right there he's he's
kicking
okay
let's see what else
thank you manero for the for the super
chat thank you
all right
elaine valance vollions if i i don't
know if i said that correctly i believe
that's french out of canada
what do you think of about the titan
the titan omaki origin of the okay i'm
sorry titan the origin of titan and the
greek gods being story linked to
atlantis
yeah guys
um history became legend legend became
myth i think all those are describing
the gods that those that were brilliant
of mine and were doing all kinds of
incredible things
i i think it's all connected and let me
also say this so the video i was working
on before i went to peru
i think it could be one of my best yet
it ties into atlantis and the sumerians
and where the so okay so atlantis
never mind if you believe whatever
location it was or whether it was called
atlantis here's the question was there
or was there not a civilization that was
relatively sophisticated i'm not saying
as advanced as ours that's a whole never
mind that debate
but a civilization that existed that was
wiped out or reset by the cataclysmic
events that happened on earth some 12
000 years ago because the younger driest
is the scientific evidence that says
that humans being alive at that time
would have been totally decimated not
extinct not dead everywhere but in many
parts of the world
completely set back
to me the answer is obviously yes to
that and and there's all the evidence to
support it
um
so i think that out of those survivors
from that cataclysm they went on to
spread and repopulate and just do what
humans do just get on with life
so they went someplace right where do
they go and what do they do and what
stories were passed down that have
unbelievable similarities to other
things i'll hold off there because i
don't want to spoil what i'm going to
say
or in that video
but it's good yeah i think you guys are
going to love it
let's see here
who else has a question let me look at
what else i was going to say
um
this is kind of a random but as far as
anyone else that wants to visit peru i
also want to tell you guys that the food
there is excellent and i took a bunch of
photos so again if you're not following
me on instagram go do that i'll make
some posts at some point of all like the
delicious
dishes and cuisines that i had
but um
yeah
that food was wonderful there guys
let's see here
any folklore from locals around lake
titicaca as to before there was a lake
there and how it appeared okay well yeah
they claimed that it was at the ocean
and it's not hard to believe when you
look at the percentage of salt
concentration
um it's not salty enough to where you
can't consume it but you can't
it won't grow plant life um at least
when used like for like agriculture
and
yeah like
this is what makes me it ties into my
thoughts that i was just saying a moment
ago about rapid crust displacement
displacement involving a pole shift
which is that maybe just maybe and this
is science fiction but it might be
reality is that certain mountains and
crusts move up and down far more
dramatically over much quicker quicker
periods of time than the slow gradual
process of just what we know about our
the current understanding of crest
movement taking
millions and millions and millions of
years
so
i mean i think it was at the ocean um
and something you should also know about
lake titicaca is that it was once 100
miles
excuse me 100 feet higher the the level
of uh the water 100 feet higher than it
is today and was literally and because
of that was 10
times the size and lake titicaca is
already massive
it is besides the fact that it's the
highest navigational lake in the world
it's also humongous it's 120 miles at
its
from one end to the other at its longest
and almost 60 miles wide at its widest
it's freaking huge and that reminds me
now
to show you guys
the
floating islands that i saw at lake
titicaca which is one of the coolest
things i've ever seen in my life
so
let's see here
look at this
what you're seeing here so keep in mind
lake titicaca is already 12 500 feet up
and what you're seeing here are reeds of
grass
lay
10 feet of of layers that go under
and and they just constantly rebuild on
top of it the water doesn't even
protrude it and they're already
rebuilding it so if it ever was or what
it does they fill over it and you see
all these huts
these so you have like hundreds of these
islands that are
lived on by by families they don't speak
spanish they don't speak the traditional
inca language
they are a culture of on themselves
they're basically autonomous
they're surrounded by bolivia and peru
governments that basically
i mean they don't even have police guys
they have their own tribal presidents
and stuff and they just live out there
they only eat fish and vegetables they
don't eat chicken or cows
and let me show you another photo
so this is on top of it like you let me
those are the huts but let me show you
this you're stepping onto reeds of grass
it is unreal and you can hear it crunch
and again
if you're not following me this is
another reason to follow me on instagram
because i have videos of this place i
can't post it on youtube i'll make a
video on youtube about it but if you
guys want to follow me on instagram i'm
not i don't endorse instagram it's i
don't like
forget it but
it's bright underscore insight if you
want to follow me on there so you can
see this cool stuff
but let me go back to this so this is me
stepping on it and you have all these
huts
and these people are totally lovely
peaceful
and this is showing how they make it
so they layer all these reeds of grass
and these are the decayed reeds of grass
which are underneath like the oh the
water eventually erodes it and it kind
of turns into like a a root-like system
but it's it's it's buoyant
and then they put the huts on top of it
so
this would be this would represent 10
feet what's under the current water and
then you'd put the hud on top of it and
these we're all just standing on it
we're in the middle of the freaking lake
and what you see over here
are other islands and then way way way
after that the hills are
you know is the land um but this is i
mean lake titicaca is so vast and
weirdly shaped that it doesn't paint you
a picture what the lake looks like
but never mind that um and by the way
some of the the deepest part of the lake
is almost a thousand feet deep it's
freaking wild
um isn't this something i mean isn't
that something oh yeah look at me gotta
get the good shot this is me on the edge
of it it's kind of creepy but it's like
you feel safe on it because you realize
like this thing is
so with every step guys
you're like bob you feel the waves
bobbing up and down
is wild
one of the most wild places i've ever
been because i was telling people like
i'm 12
500 feet up in the middle of lake
titicaca in the peruvian andes
on an island made out of grass
then he had to take a boat to get to
i was like this is one of the craziest
things i've ever been to in such a great
way
um
this is the edge of lake titicaca and
some of the guys we went with they went
swimming in there
i didn't do it because i didn't feel
like
if i was staying in this area i would
have gone swimming in lake titicaca that
would be awesome but they had to like
you know bring towels and get their
whole set up for themselves i didn't
feel like doing it but hold on let me
read a couple super chats because i
don't want to leave anyone behind
all right src jimmy is no longer science
fiction i have a paper from with data on
the pole flip proven and up thrust
values and known research gate jovian
octagons thanks brother so i believe it
i'm telling you that's what my gut tells
me anyways i believe it but i i'm
careful when i'm
speaking in front of an audience like
there's 4 000 people on here right now
and i'm like so i want to if i'm going
to present this i want to do it like
with awesome evidence but like dude i'm
with you that's what i think is going on
i think that some of these mountain
chains guys were developed far more
quicker than people want to believe
and i know it sounds like science
fiction but
whatevs
all right someone wrote
ellie howard or eli granite melts at 2
300 degrees fahrenheit there are caves
near saxe woman with signs of a type of
melt glass which happens at
high heat have you heard of a theory of
caves used as
kelms to soften rocks
not that specifically
what i was saying earlier in the in this
uh live stream was that
um
there is a plant that used to grow or
allegedly had used to grow in the
peruvian andes that could soften stone
and make granite malleable
like a marshmallow not pour it not like
concrete but this is going to tie into a
video
um let's see here and then i want to get
on to some other points i have
um
can you say hello to donna beckett she's
a huge fan hi donna beckett don i don't
know who you are
but thanks for watching it's pretty
surreal to be
making a live stream right now
with so many people watching and people
from all over the world that would just
want to shout out for me i don't even
know what to say other than i'm totally
grateful
it's surreal
and thank you because you guys keep me
going
that is lovely
um
jd jones let's
expedition to atlantis it will require
gathering experts from all fields of
science and engineering in addition to
men and women trained in armed combat
damn right and likely a decade to
properly plan it so he i assume you're
referring to the wrist shot
structure in mauritania if that's the
case i got a few things to say about it
right now
and let me also say hi to my buddy matt
who went with me on to egypt and in peru
and because he wants to go there as well
and if i go there i'm not going without
him so let me that reminds me before i
get into the wrist shot because that's
gonna be a tangent let me show you guys
something real quick here
so these are my friends so the eight of
us here
yarda me mike matt ben
um
[Music]
excuse me tyler and um ivan excuse me
ivan you know um so eight of us all met
in egypt and now this is all of us in
peru
at lake titicaca
guys this is the like this is why i'm
telling you like if you're tempted to go
on a tour
this is
do it like you're gonna make friends
like it's surreal to think we all were
in the great pyramid together and now we
all went to peru together
and like these are friends i'll have
forever
good people from all over the world and
um
i don't know guys like because i was
just thinking about that when when you
mentioned matt because this is matt he
wants to go to the wrist shot and he was
saying the same thing like we need to
plan this out this guy's that's a big
deal mauritania is dangerous my buddy
joshua gertzon went there and he almost
freaking died one he almost start well
not starve to death but he was starving
because this is as third world as it
gets and they almost they had to drive
through a freaking minefield from these
mines had been out there for decades in
the middle of nowhere
and uh and they passed skeletons along
the way from people who had blown up on
the mines like you have to take a
certain path
water is an issue you can only carry so
much reliable transportation's a thing
according to the united states state
department
kidnappings and ransoms are a real thing
out there and americans are in jeopardy
that's not what josh saw
josh said he saw the most nicest most
giving most welcoming
people he's ever met in his life
and that's exactly what i saw when i was
in iraq and my deployment that on the
outskirts the people in the middle of
nowhere were the nicest most welcoming
people
ever
and i think because most of humanity is
good guys
but all of that said
being
a veteran that's done almost a full year
deployment
you know
i can't go to a country like that
without me being strapped i need a piece
i need a i need a rifle i need an ak-47
and
and besides that though because that's
just me i'll never be able to live
within that mindset of terminal
vulnerability in a place where i don't
feel unsafe like i don't let me say i do
not go to the jimmy does not go to the
woods without a gun
and by a gun i mean i have my freaking
glock and at least a shotgun and maybe
my ar and maybe something else like
and i'm not even afraid of the animals
i'm more afraid of people
you know
anyway but that aside in mauritania they
do not allow drones they do not allow
ground penetrating radar and you want to
hear something interesting about that
because they don't want any the reason
is is because they don't want anyone
taking their gold because mauritania is
rich in gold it's like the third
most export or one of the highest
exports there
think about that
so i mean atlantis was said to be rich
in gold
mauritania has lots of gold so let's
talk about the wrist shot structure
um and real quick before i do that
because i know it's going to be a
tangent let me just read off a couple of
the super chats
will rc because i'm going to get on i
just want to read these off thank you
will uh love you smearing egyptian work
exposing the truth thanks brother
nathan what up
lungfi jing zhang i i didn't say that
right forgive me hey jimmy 1982 paper on
how stones were softened using plant
extract making cement with plant
extracts joseph screen let me screenshot
this
thank you that's totally going in a
video just what i need because it's one
thing to be like make a video say i
heard this and all that but i need the
paper
jelqs
cabernet
you just gave me a hundred and you
didn't say anything
this is surreal guys you guys are
generous
oh my god
thank you
anthony
de stefano thanks brother okay so who
wants to talk about the shot structure
real quick
i got a few things to say because you
saw my previous video on the topic
um of
the declassified cia documents on the
reshot structure with the navy
conducting secret
missions to go study it nothing about
that is related to atlantis or lost
ancient civilizations
but they did study it it was classified
for decades it was declassified in the
early 2000s but nobody do it without the
freedom of information act being in
place and being a thing as well as the
online community to be able to expose
that stuff so how else would you know
um but i find that really interesting
and
let me just say because i've seen like
randall carlson make videos on this
and i respect reynold carlson's opinion
above most anybody else uh his work on
on catastro uh catastrophe sega geometry
everything high respect but he does not
think that's the location at all he's
partial towards azores and if you
haven't guys randall carlson you know
him from joe rogan and graham hancock he
has a youtube channel guys
um go
subscribe to his channel and listen to
all of his work on discussing atlantis
it's fascinating and for me personally
i'm still partial towards the richard
now he has certain reasons why he thinks
it's not likely to be the case
he is open-minded enough to say when he
was pressed on it that perhaps it could
be but but he doesn't think it's it's a
location let me be clear um and when i
made that prior video i was trying to be
very respectful to him because he was
respectful to me he's never said
anything about jimmy's thoughts on it he
just talks about the rich shot in
atlantis because he's a gentleman he's a
class act so i want to pay the same
thing forward to say that i'm not
disagreeing with him i'm just discussing
the wrist shot because to me there's so
many uncanny similarities that
i don't think we can just ignore this
site
the ocean the striations of water
erosion has been proven as confirmed by
randall carlson that is undoubtedly
water erosion that stripped the bedrock
across all of northern africa
guys when and how did that freaking
happen and why is there salt on top of
it
it's not 100 certainty that the salt
has been there since
atlantis or 12 000 years let's say maybe
it's older than that all i know is that
there's sand that has blown in that has
the water ripples just like seen at the
dry falls area all across washington
montana that's been proven to have been
a result of the end of the last ice age
with the catastrophic flooding and the
melting of the ice caps
and it's the same huge massive water
ripples
seen in both spots so i'm like how old
are these water ripples that are made of
sand or or or that have carved the
bedrock and sand has come on top of them
to fill them up so it's like
i don't i would argue that was done in
the last 12 000 years
i don't think that's unreasonable to
suggest and the fact there's sand on top
of it to me
is a strong indicator that this
that the ocean had flowed through it
more recently than
50 plus million years ago like they
claim okay
so
also a lot of people want to debate
about the sizes that's like one of the
biggest arguments is that people say
it's too high above sea level well like
hold on it's already the crest moves up
and down so that's one thing
um but and especially if you want to
believe that atlantis could have sank
well then you could believe that it
could have risen too i mean like
volcanic activity north africa has been
covered with it and it's not hard to
suggest that the crust in certain parts
of it have lifted over 12 000 years
um i already gave the example on how a
freaking
1200 or 1500 foot uh
the volcano in mexico the um i forgot
the name this is my most recent video on
how that sucker rose more than a
thousand feet or whatever it was in less
than a year or whatever i mean forgive
me on getting this the proper
measurements go watch the video but i'm
like come on
but there's that and then other people
want to argue the measurements they're
like well this the wrist shot's too big
okay well atlantis was said to be busy
all day and all night it was said to be
bustling and trade spoken from languages
of all over and many modern scholars
suggest that that would imply that there
was a populace of millions of people
at the capitol in that area
which is not unreasonable to suggest
because it sounds like modern day new
york right like bustling with trade busy
all day all night numerous languages
a whole bunch of people
but if you look at
the described the modernly described
measurements of atlantis
it's capital the capital itself i'm like
i don't think that's big enough to hold
millions of people at least not without
high density living like skyscrapers and
the such
so
all of that said and knowing that it's a
12 000 plus year old story that was
passed down by no less than three
languages the ancient egyptians the
ancient greek and now let's say
not just english but any modern language
i'll count those all in as one
but it's good that's no less than three
but it's going to be more than that
because
why
if the ancient egyptians of just a
couple thousand years ago were speaking
one language
it is unbelievably likely that the
people of atlantis whoever they were
speaking an entirely different language
and different languages between then and
the
9 000 or so or whatever years before
that
or but in between i should say
so i don't know guys when you when we
discuss loss in translation that is 100
a real thing things get lost in
translation and i do not believe that a
system of measurement could mean
maintain
precise
um continuity over a period of 12 000
years 13 000 years whatever nope i don't
think that for a second it's possible
maybe i don't know i can admit i don't
know
but i think that anyone completely
ruling out the wrist shot i think it's
premature i respect anyone that
disagrees with it and there is doubt
guys i'm not 100 certain on this thing i
i know that there's doubt there
but
i don't think people should just dismiss
it just yet there's too many uncanny
similarities like three rings of water
to land
i think that we need to entertain what's
possible here on earth over that period
of time
but um let me read off some of these
super chats
you guys are
oh my god you guys are too nice
dan palladino living vicariously through
you jimmy cheerist
brother
thank you
that means it's like surreal um d smith
i'm a full believer oh i'm sorry you
already said that i'm scrolling back
okay good i didn't miss these
thank you misty fifty dollars from missy
just saying thank you thank you
i owe you a beer i appreciate and all
right i'm sorry uh murloc confidential i
appreciate a marvel at your adventures
and information sharing that's very kind
of you
cam and das thank you for the ten bucks
okay craig tinsley do you think it's
possible that ancient history has been
whitewashed and there may be
anti-black racism in the ancient
historical narrative love the info you
do bro i have something to say on that
let me take a sip of my because i'm
still my first beer give me a second
here
because it's warm and flat
okay so let me read off a quote to you
i'm not read off let me just say it so
anyone that remembers john anthony west
the legendary john anthony west when he
was on the joe rogan podcast he ran off
it wasn't his own quote but he he read
it he said it he's like
it was something to the effect of not
only were the atlantean not only did the
atlanteans exist
but they were black and he said that he
was totally partial towards that but
guys if if i would argue that the
ancient egyptians
are the most we're the most advanced and
sophisticated of all the ancient
civilizations that's debatable i'm
seeing unreal stuff in india and other
places so i can't say that with absolute
certainty and some of the stuff i just
saw in peru was unbelievable so
maybe maybe maybe not but egypt's in
africa and now looking at everything
that happened to sahara desert guys i
think that
[Applause]
whether we humans originated in africa
or not is debated now now it used to be
the consensus now there's different
things either way i i don't know the
answers
but to be honest with you i am one of
those people that thinks that
i know this is a touchy subject but yeah
i think that
i can't say african-american i just say
black right that's the word because
we're not talking about african-american
we're talking about people of the skin
color with melanin coming from africa
i do believe that
there is a lot more to that history
throughout that continent and i think
there's a whole bunch of people in
modern times that either
don't think so or don't want to believe
or
whatever or maybe the evidence has since
gone so since gone or whatever
i think there's something to be said for
that i don't guys i don't give a [ __ ]
about color you know i who cares either
you're an [ __ ] or you're nice right
either you're a dumbass or you have
something fun to chat about right either
you're you're kind or you're a prick
like
i don't know i just think that everyone
agrees on the same thing i feel like the
whole media is trying to push racism
more than ever just to divide people
does it exist sure hell yeah there's
some real stupid people out there but
like that's the common denominator with
anyone that ever known that was racist
they're like totally dumb they're so
close-minded they don't do anything they
don't travel they don't they go to the
same restaurant or the same plate every
single time you know what i'm talking
about like it's so stupid and i think
that uh
i don't know i want to get a
preachy get me off this soapbox right
now but i'm like i don't know i think
that everyone i talk to it's always says
the same thing it's like
99 well never mind i can't say that
vast majority of people out there are
not racist at all and they just want to
do good
and everyone i talk to it seems to say
the same thing every once in a while you
come across some bigot
but like
who cares don't talk to him don't give
him attention or whatever i don't know
i'll just shut up on that now but um
but that all being said yeah it's a
thing like i think some people don't
want to believe
the capabilities of certain races out
there i don't know i'll just shut up
okay tyler scott said everything still
sounds good good
the audio is good thank you
um hold on here i don't want to skip
anyone
coming to us all right
brian the broken 50 bucks dude thank you
alien aliens oh yeah ancient sites oh
yeah i think that we have come from
asian civilizations to survive the
cataclysm right there with you brother
thank you for that super chat
theoj keep up the incredible work
brother thank you
bp there is a video called the golden
sun that is loosely based on our world
names of our ancient sites and cultures
that are very similar lemuria is one so
that's a whole other topic guys is that
makes me wonder is like lumeria atlantis
are the two different things
described in two different places
both all i know is that if you're
referring to what's supposed to be under
the pacific ocean
it would sure would explain certain
things that machu picchu or excuse me i
should say certain things at peru
as in found uh at easter island that's
what i was looking for
because easter island's like 2 400 miles
off the coast of chile
and uh some of the stonework is
absolutely identical to a certain site
or two in peru
the connection's there
academics say it doesn't exist
it's not possible for
easter island and peru to have had a
connection
that's a consensus however not all
academics agree on that so that's the
good thing is that people are more some
people are open-minded and it's clear as
day so when i think of east island i
think of lumeria if you're talking about
like a sunken civilization in the
pacific that was alleged to have existed
i'm with you
okay
sebastian awesome bastion
okay hold on a donation in memory of the
machu picchu cow great travel hold on
sebastian is like one of my best buddies
i made on this trip let me show the cow
here
um hold on sebastian sebastian was the
best photo taker so if you guys are
looking sebastian lombarge i forgot you
told me how to say it but he's from
sweden so it's difficult for me to say
he took the best photos of me at these
sites
literally the best photos he took this
one of me with the alpaca which
look at that sucker
oh yeah and then he also took
this one of me with the cow and that's
just the one you're seeing i have one
with almost lips on but
didn't want to put on the internet just
yet um
dude sebastian i miss you already i hope
your
that triple seven
klm flight went good back home brother
we'll uh see this is an example of
something i'm gonna stay in touch with
with forever guys this i'm telling you
you go on these sites like or these
these trips these tours you're gonna
make friends
it's a good time and like now it's
surreal like sitting i'm in my kitchen
with this
crazy setup of me having this uh
tv that i set up behind me and now i'm
online talking to sebastian
well we'll have to talk over the phone
soon brother
kyra please do more live streams we miss
you
right on
adam davis also curious on your thoughts
on the origins of the cp evils okay man
that literally ties precisely into what
i was sharing a few minutes a little bit
earlier involving the video i want to
make on where the survivors of atlantis
went
so
stay tuned on that uh because well i'll
just tell you i think that the so-called
sea people that's what they're
describing
that the people came from the sea that's
the best way to explain it i would say
oh at least i'm gonna argue but there's
some other details that i came across
while doing some other studies that
there's put this way there's some things
out there that i never heard of before
that i think are unbelievably compelling
similarities on some different cultures
that is worthy of some attention
let's see here
um hold on oh my god i've just realized
i've had the whole chat frozen
can you guys oh my god
hold on here
hold on you guys all still got me
north africa was all right let's see
here
josh randall says i owe you a 12 at the
wrist shot what's a 12
what does
that mean oh like a 12 pack
sure they're better than a six-pack if
that's what you mean um
thought on fire222 hey jimmy cheers the
sumerians referred to themselves as
quote the black-headed people one love
that's interesting
um
interesting
all right so hold on let me look at my
little syllabus and other things i want
to chat about
let's see here
sebastian with the cow that's so funny
hey you want to see the highest point
that i got up to
so
look at this
you see that
look at that
that is what is that in meters i thought
i think it was forgive me it might be 4
300 meters but 14
310 feet was the elevation i got up to
and i've never felt experienced anything
like that before in my life
um what the hell is the photo of it
hold
on
there's a picture of me up there i
thought it was pretty cool
oh well i can't see it next time i'll
lay this out different next time i do a
live stream i'll do i'll do better
hold on a second what's crc
because james starling just gave me 2500
of it
that is worthy of a quick google search
what currency is
crc
okay so let's see oh it's costa rica duh
right on nice
let's see let me do 2500 crc to us
dollars oh nice dude that's
thank you so much i had to double check
though to make sure that wasn't some
insane dollar amount you know oh he
retracted he retracted his message but
thank you so much james starling i
appreciate it i hope i didn't put you on
the spot man
um
let's see
thought on fire i read that thank you
brian the broken when are you going to
do a live stream with randall carlson
make it happen love your channel it's a
great question i want to do it very much
so
i left a comment so he made a recent
video in response to johanna james on
his channel guys go subscribe to randall
carlson you'll find his channel on
youtube very easily he's only got like
50 000 subscribers he should have way
more but he's you know he's just getting
it going in the last year or so and um i
don't he's not i don't think he's
pushing it as much as in some ways um
but like
his content's gold and anyways long
story short he had tagged me in in the
description of it because it was related
to atlantis and other stuff
and um so i left a comment saying like
hey like randall i would love to
chat with you podcast format we don't
i mean atlantis is one topic which would
be fun to talk about but more than
anything i want to talk to him about is
the moon he has some very very
interesting thoughts on the moon that
coincide with things that i've already
believed and thought i think the moon is
one of the most interesting mysterious
sites in the entire solar system and he
seems to be all about it
um all right so james starling he said
hi jimmy what do you know about the
stone spheres of costa rica well i don't
know much i know that they claim they're
totally natural and that's not what my
eyes see i don't think they're natural i
don't know what they would have been
but i don't see how they're natural
so to answer your question
yeah i think they're ancient i don't
think we know what they are
i just really don't think they're
natural
i could be wrong
but i think they're pretty wild and i
mentioned in one of my earlier videos i
think
mundo fox in ancient history it has to
some kind of global trade different
cultures from around the world having
the same
idea excuse me
to build the pyramids use constellations
constellation stuff i don't know what i
do think is that it's not an accident or
a coincidence that
you have
cultures from across the world building
pyramids i discussed this in my ancient
connection video from like a year and a
half ago or whatever it was and no i
don't think that's a coincidence
the academics will say that it is i
think that's silly i think that
there it's just like in modern day
there's skyscrapers all over the world
and they all look different and you have
similar but different techniques to
build them in structures and they all
might look some look different than
others
and i think the same thing about the
pyramids it was inspired somewhere
wherever that was first i couldn't say
100 certainty i suspect egypt or at
least i don't disagree with it
um some people will say in cambodia may
have come first i don't know the answer
what came first what i do know is that
they're all over the world and to me it
implies a global trade a global
connection where
because you've got to keep in mind i try
to explain this to people they're
currently teaching in school that none
of these cultures had any type of
connection at all it wasn't possible
they could not have
traveled the ocean in the way that is
alleged uh to be able to do that and and
and so they couldn't possibly be
connected end of story and i think
that's silly and i think the evidence
suggests otherwise and i just think that
there's this dogmatic approach to what
the academics claim is this is true this
is not true and i'm like can't you just
say you don't know or just say like well
we have reason to believe this or
perhaps this is true but we don't have
enough evidence to support it this time
so let's keep digging you have a bunch
of people writing textbooks and making a
fortune and tenured professors that
making 250 000 plus a year and like they
want to just be right and that's the end
of it end of story it's pathetic
um
dora cooper hi from sarasota florida we
love your videos jimmy keep on traveling
thank you dora i really appreciate that
ray hule if i say that right
if the moon has academic and
intellectual economic value why haven't
we been back
well it certainly does and you should
look into
china russia
and
um the us all in a rush to go mine the
moon
oh they're in a hurry and this might
tell people to think that we haven't
been there i'm like well
someone's been there because we sure in
a rush to go there and mine that place
there's some real money to be made there
um
so i think that that's a smoking gun
that we've been there at some point in
fact i tell people it's not about when
we first cause apollo 11 you can debate
that all you want but i say it's not
about when we first went the question is
when's the last time people were there
and i think there's been missions there
where people i would bet i don't have
any evidence to support this but i think
that humans have been back there since
1972.
i think that it could easily be done and
here's how you send a craft from space
and you put people into space without
the public knowing through
those
uh satellite launches that are being
done there's been thousands of satellite
launches where they they send satellites
allegedly to outer space
but the compartment is completely top
secret as in because those satellite
military satellites for example are top
secret like you'll have a rocket
engineer down below
that doesn't get to know what's inside
the or or what the satellite has it's
none of their business it's in the cargo
area and that's it and i think you could
put people in there
and send them up to a craft that was
pieced together and out of space it
doesn't have to be anything crazy
and just send them to the moon over a
period of a few days or a week or
whatever and i think it could be done
and i think it's been done because i
think that there's certain things they
know about the moon
that aren't explainable for what we're
being told now like i mentioned this in
my moon video guys there's this huge
rush to go mine the place for all these
different metals and precious elements
and it's like wait a second i don't
remember anything not one single thing
from the apollo moon missions that
talked about like oh hey there's a bunch
of money to be made on the moon someday
we're going to come back and mine it
real well real good someday
nothing literally nothing have you heard
anything about that right i don't know
anyone that's ever heard that nobody so
at what point did they figure that out
did they keep it did they go there and
figure it out in the apollo 11 missions
in the late 60s and early 70s and then
just decide to keep it secret sure maybe
that's right maybe probably
or or we've been back to investigate
more things since
and if nothing else if it's not people
then what about drones never mind
secretly sending humans to the moon
i would have sent him a a drone to the
moon and you could do it top secret
again when i say i would have if i had
unlimited resources
like if i worked for the department of
defense and it was some top secret stuff
which we know they have and they have
black money where we don't know how much
money is going where and to who and to
what that's real you gotta have to start
asking questions and i'm sorry if jimmy
was running the show
i'd rather be at the moon right now
maybe not me personally but i'd be
watching it on camera as i play with it
like my drone on my own little remote
control i would totally do that and have
some scientists behind me helping me the
whole way
um
let me see here who else says a super
chat let's see i don't want to
oh hold on i'm missing something forgive
me
all right randall carlson one the moon
is interesting i have seen objects fly
from the moon through my telescope but
they were not in orbit not to mention
some things the astronauts saw that
there was a port out there the moon is
hollow guys
yes i a lot of people have reported
seeing different things on the moon you
go on youtube and watch people
telescopes seeing some weird stuff
happening there flashes of light
that could be i mean that could be
meteor impacts but i've seen things that
are sustained lighting
and um
yeah like there's
as far as like it being hollow i mean
the seismographs they set up in the
apollo missions there's like half a
dozen of them across several hundred
miles
and
the whenever there's like they throw
like a shuttle into it